Hallo! Guten Morgen! Wie geht's?
Mir geht's gut. Und dir?
Gut!
Du bist Flip oder Steffen?
Ich bin Steffen. Flip fährt da hinten mit dem Fahrrad herum.
Morgen! Hi Flip! Perfekt!
Okay. Wie ist die Lage?
Super, Danke!
Euer Film läuft in den Niederlanden bereits super und
in Deutschland ist er vor einigen Tagen erst angelaufen.
Ja richtig, er ist dieses Wochenende angelaufen und ich habe gehört
wir stehen im Moment auf Platz 1 der Ticketverkäufe. Das ist wirklich toll!
Okay, das ist toll! Und wie hat das alles eigentlich angefangen?
Ich denke es war ja etwas recht kleines am Anfang.
Ja, das stimmt! Im Grunde genommen haben wir vor zehn Jahren damit angefangen, zusammen mit Freunden Sketche zu machen.
Also so kleine 3-minütige Filmchen. Wir haben das für einen Fernsehsender gemacht.
Es war mit denselben Schauspielern, alles Freunde von uns.
Aus Maaskantje?
Aus der kleinen Stadt in Brabant.
Ja, aus Maaskantje und Umgebung.
Er lebte zu der Zeit in Den Bosch, das ist so eine größere Stadt nahe Maaskantje.
Dann gab es auch Leute aus Eindhoven, aber wir kannten uns alle von früher.
Wir haben einfach angefangen, lustige Sachen zu machen. Es war im Fernsehen zu sehen, aber kein richtig großer Erfolg oder sowas.
Unser Plan war dann, etwas längeres zu machen. Deshalb begannen wir, Sketche zu machen.
Neue Sketche und ohne jegliches Budget, aber niemand wollte sie, weil sie zu frech angreifend waren.
Keiner dachte, dass sie wirklich erfolgreich werden würden. Also haben wir sie im Internet veröffentlicht.
Aber wann genau war das? Youtube ist fünf Jahre alt und eure Sketche zehn Jahre.
Ja, da sind ein paar Jahre dazwischen, aber alles begann vor zehn Jahren.
Ich ging zur Filmschule und er arbeitete damals bei MTV.
Nach meiner Zeit an der Filmschule haben wir es wieder aufgenommen, weil wir mehr machen wollten. Wir haben alle diese... Wie sagt man...
Naja, wir wollten etwas machen, das wirklich unser Eigenes ist.
Sachen, die uns gefallen. Das war ungefähr 2005. Dann haben wir mit diesem holländischen Blog "Flabber" zusammengearbeitet
und dort unsere Sketche veröffentlicht, die eigentlich keiner sehen wollte.
Weil sie zu unhöflich waren.
Genau. Sie waren zu grob. Und die Leute glaubten einfach nicht an die Sketche.
Und die Sache ist die: Die TV-Sender wollten eher etwas anderes machen.
Für uns war sehr wichtig, das machen zu könne, was uns gefällt. Ansonsten hätten wir auch bei McDonalds arbeiten können, glaube ich.
00:03:56.000,00:03:10.683
Ich hab gehört die suchen da gerade Leute, also wenn eventuell jemand da arbeiten möchte, das ist noch möglich!
Du kannst es auch gerne auf Deutsch versuchen.
Nein nein, da drin bin ich sehr schlecht. Ich spreche ein bietschen...
Ein bisschen. Ja, es ist schwer.
F**ze, Junge, ...
Okay okay okay. Ihr habt etwas geübt für euren Film, denn ihr habt ihn ja selber synchrongesprochen.
Ja richtig, aber wir haben es nur vorgelesen.
Naja und im Internet hat es dann irgendwann funktioniert und es wurde zum Hype.
Wir sprachen dann mit Comedy Central und die wollten es wagen, es mit uns zu versuchen.
Sie gaben uns alle Freiheiten. Wir machten ein paar neue Sketches mit neuen Charakteren, den New Kids,
die ja heute noch in den Sketchen existieren. Es wurde ein riesen Hit im Internet und auch im Fernsehen.
Es war also wirklich die Kombination aus Beidem. Wir sind auch sehr dankbar für's Internet.
Für uns ist das der beste Weg, um direkt zu sehen, wie die Leute auf Etwas reagieren und ob sie es mögen.
Also das wurde ein Hit.
Und es war kein Problem, solche derben Sketche im Fernsehen zu zeigen?
Doch, es war ein Problem. Da gab es ein paar Sketche, die zu derb waren.
Aber wir haben beschlossen, sie einfach zu machen und der Fernsehsender sollte dann aussuchen,
welche sie ausstrahlen wollen und welche ihnen zu grob waren.
Am Anfang haben wir ungefähr 20 Sketche gemacht und die ersten 12 wurden ausgestrahlt.
Die anderen 8 waren zu grob. So ungefähr oder?
Aber am Ende haben sie dann doch alles ausgestrahlt. Erst waren es kleine Schnipsel in Werbeunterbrechungen
und als Zuschauer hat man gedacht "Oh was zum Teufel, was ist das?".
Und wir haben das dann alles zusammengesetzt und es funktioniert besser. Man kann auch grober sein, weil es im Kontext ist.
Ja .... Wir landeten dann einen Hit im Internet.
Wir haben einen Song gemacht mit den Rappern "The Opposites" und es wurde ein Nummer-Eins-Hit in Holland.
Wir hatten dann den Plan, einen Film zu machen. Das war lange Zeit unser Traum.
Etwas unglaubliches.
Ja. Und in einem Interview im Fernsehen wurden wir auch einmal nach unseren TrÄumen gefragt und wir sagten:
"Einen Film zu machen". Und ich glaube einen Monat spÄter bekamen wir einen Anruf von Eyeworks, der Produktionsfirma.
Sie wollten sich mit uns treffen. Wir sagten ihnen dann, dass wir es nur machen würden, wenn wir die volle Kontrolle haben.
Hatten die keine Angst?
Nein, sie glaubten daran. Ja und jetzt gibt es New Kids Turbo.
Ja okay. Aber in Deutschland können nicht alle den Film sehen. Wenn man unter 16 Jahren ist,
darf man diesen Film nicht anschauen. Das ist schade!
Die sind hier ein bisschen lockerer in Holland was Altersbeschränkungen angeht.
Aber in Deutschland wurde der Film ja zuerst als 18+ eingestuft.
Ja, und damit kommt der Film auf dieselbe Stufe wie Pornos.
Naja, das war also wirklich ein Problem. Aber letztendlich war der Film dann ab 16 Jahren erlaubt. Das freut uns sehr!
Diese Grobheit könnte ein Problem werden für euch. Im Fernsehen, im Kino, ...
Ja, aber es ist immer in einem lustigen Zusammenhang. Also es ist nicht so dass wir wirklich grauenhafte Sachen machen wollen.
Es muss immer lustig sein, weil es ja Comedy ist.
Ja, verstehe. Aber wo kam diese Grobheit her? Ist das die Jugend in Brabant, die so ungezogen ist? Oder war eure Jugend so?
Das witzige ist: Maaskantje ist eine recht wohlhabende kleine Stadt mit rund 1500 Einwohnern.
Aber da gab es ein paar Typen, .... Ich bin ja aus Maaskantje.
Und wo kommst du her? Auch aus Maaskantje?
Nein, ich habe in Den Bosch gewohnt, das ist in der NÄhe von Maaskantje. Daher kenne ich ihn.
Also da gab es immer diese paar Typen, die auf dem Platz herumstanden. Sie hatten einen Opel.
Ich glaube es war zu der Zeit kein Manta sondern ein Opel Astra oder so etwas.
Ich ging an ihnen vorbei und war beeindruckt. Diese Typen haben uns auf eine Art und Weise inspiriert.
Wir haben das dann ein bisschen übertrieben.
Und was sagen die Leute in Maaskantje jetzt über eure Gang?
Ist es ihnen ein bisschen peinlich?
Ja, die Sache ist die: Weil wir von dort kommen, sind sie stolz auf uns.
Sie sind stolz. Okay.
Ja. Weißt du, wenn wir aus einer anderen Stadt kÄmen, wÄre das bestimmt schlimm für sie,
weil wir uns über die Leute lustig machen würden. Aber da wir ja von dort kommen finden sie es cool.
Natürlich hat jeder eine Meinung und das ist auch gut so. Man liebt es oder man hasst es.
Das mögen wir auch daran. Wir sind eigentlich auch sehr extrem, wenn es um GeschmÄcker geht.
Wenn wir schreiben und einen Witz machen und der andere sagt "Der ist Scheiße!", dann ist er scheiße.
Dann macht er einen Witz und er ist gut. Verstehst du? Entweder es ist gut oder nicht gut.
Und dasselbe ist es beim Publikum auch. Man liebt uns oder man hasst uns.
Lieben oder hassen eure Freunde eure Sketche? Oder ist das Fifty-Fifty?
Sie mögen sie. Für uns ist es sehr wichtig, dass wir Dinge machen, von denen wir denken, dass sie lustig sind.
Aber das erste richtig große Kompliment ist, wenn deine Freunde mögen, was du machst.
Von Anfang an hatten wir immer Viewings, wo wir unseren Freunden unsere Sachen gezeigt und vorgespielt haben.
Sie mögen unsere Sachen und das ist sehr schön für uns.
Also ihr beiden schreibt die meisten New Kids Sketche? Wie wichtig ist Bier dabei?
Bier ist immer wichtig!
Wenn man schreibt, wenn man sich die Sachen anschaut, oder einfach nichts tut. Es ist immer wichtig!
Also ist es auch wichtig fürs Schreiben?
Ich rauche gerne Gras. Das funktioniert gut.
Ja, das wars eigentlich. Gras und Bier.
Okay. Ich bin gerade die Straße herunter gelaufen und habe einen Coffee Shop gesehen.
Mögt ihr solche Coffee Shops hier in Amsterdam?
Ja, klar. Man findet sie überall. Ich bin ein wichtiger Kunde.
Okay. Also du meinst, Drogen können positiv sein?
Gras kann positiv sein.
Ich mag das harte Zeug nicht.
Was denkst du darüber? Über Bier und Gras?
Manchmal funktioniert es sehr gut und manchmal nicht. Wir denken uns Sachen aus und trinken dabei, aber am Ende trinken wir nur noch.
Also manchmal ist es besser nichts zu trinken wenn man schreibt. Aber manchmal ist es ehr
gut.
Viele Situationen entstehen erst, wenn man trinkt. Und wir verwenden solche alltäglichen Situationen in unseren Skripts.
Wir haben immer ein kleines Buch dabei und alles witzige, was uns begegnet, schreiben wir rein
für unser nÄchstes Projekt oder so. Wir haben immer eine Liste mit Witzen parat.
Okay. Wann schreibt ihr die witzigsten Sachen in euer kleines Buch?
Im Urlaub. Wenn ich nichts zu tun habe und irgendwo am Strand liege.
Man sieht eine Menge irritierender Leute, die vorbeilaufen. Man denkt sich
00:13:15.000,00:13:09.683
"Mann, das wär lustig, wenn dem Typen das jetzt passieren würde."
Im Urlaub gibt es also viel Inspiration.
Also Leute beobachten.
Ich glaube Hass ist sehr gut.
Hass?
Wenn man von Leuten genervt ist. Wie Flip schon sagte, man denkt es wäre jetzt cool wenn etwas vom Himmel fällt,
auf den einen Typ drauf und er ist tot. Nicht im Ernst, aber als Gedankenspiel.
Also wenn Hass eine gute Inspiration ist: Habt ihr viele Hater auf Youtube und anderen Platformen?
Ja ja klar, ich überlege nur. Ich denke schon, aber die Leute im Internet mögen hauptsächlich New Kids.
Es gibt natürlich auch richtige Hater, die nerven.
Die meisten Hater sind auf dem Blog, auf dem unsere Filme am Anfang zu sehen waren.
Die Filme waren dort jede Woche zu sehen und diese Leute, die Seit langer Zeit diese Seite verfolgten,
sagten "Verpisst euch, das ist unser Blog! Was zum Teufel macht ihr hier?".
Man hat immer Hater. Aber das ist auch gut. Wenn alles immer nur so ruhig und nett wÄre,
wäre es mittelmäßig. Wir mögen es, dass die Reaktionen so extrem sind.
Okay und wenn ihr sagt, Hass sei eine gute Inspiration: Liebt oder hasst ihr die New Kids als Rollen?
Oder habt ihr sogar Angst vor ihnen?
Im echten Leben, wenn ich sie treffen würde?
Vielleicht.
Ich habe keine Angst vor ihnen. Ich finde sie interessant.
Ja. Sie leben nach ihren eigenen Regeln. Sie haben ihren eigenen Lebensraum.
Ich mag an ihnen, dass es ihr eigener Ort ist, ihre Welt, ihre Regeln. Es ist alles da!
Ich mag das. Ich bin nicht einer von ihnen aber ich mag es.
Verstehen oder missverstehen sie die Welt?
Ich denke sie benutzen die Welt für sich selbst.
Und es funktioniert sehr gut für sie. Sie haben eine Menge Spaß.
Wie heißt der Typ mit dem Opel Manta?
Ja, Rikkert. Er ist sehr stolz auf seinen Opel Manta.
Aber ich denke der Rest der Welt wÄre nicht so stolz auf einen Opel Manta.
Nein. Mann, er liebt sein Auto! Damals war dieses Auto in Deutschland ja auch eine große Sache.
Ja klar, wir hatten einen Film über den Opel Manta.
Manta, Manta!
Das war das coolste Auto. Es wurde ein Hit, als es schon ein bisschen Älter war.
Junge Leute konnten es sich dann leisten. Und Mann, es ist so hÄsslich, das ist schon wieder toll!
Besonders in grün!
Ja, besonders in grün! Und es ist sogar ein deutscher Manta. Er wurde aus Deutschland importiert.
Das war witzig. Der Typ lebt in Holland, aber ist Deutscher. Er hat sein eigenes Auto gepimpt und ...
Er hat euch sein Auto gegeben?
Ja, wir haben es benutzt, weil wir ja am Anfang kein Geld hatten.
Wir haben einfach die Sketche gemacht. Wir mussten Leute fragen, ob sie uns helfen.
Er war halt ein Typ, der dieses Auto hatte und wir dachten nur "Wow!". Erst dachten wir,
es müsste ein schwarzes Auto sein. Aber dann haben wir dieses Auto gesehen und waren begeistert.
Es ist echt grün, Mann!
Und der echte Typ, dem das Auto gehört, hat der sich nicht gedacht
"Was machen die denn mit meinem Auto?"
Nein, er fÄhrt selber Rennen mit dem Auto. Er liebt es.
Er mag New Kids?
Er ist nicht wie einer der Charaktere in New Kids?
Nein, nein. Die New Kids Charaktere sind ja auch ein bisschen aus der Vergangenheit,
inspiriert von den Neunzigern. Der Typ, dem der Manta gehört, ist richtig cool.
Er mag House Musik, aber eher aus der Gegenwart.
Was denkt ihr über New Kids? Ist es manchmal für euch peinlich,
eine solche Comedy zu machen? Oder steht ihr da drüber?
Es ist ja manchmal peinlich, solche derben Witze zu machen.
Nein, das ist für uns nur die Art, die wir lustig finden. So leben wir unseren Traum.
Der beste Job, den man haben kann ist der, den wir gerade machen.
Okay. Ich wünsche euch viele Filme in der Zukunft. New Kids Turbo, New Kids Nitro und der dritte ist ...
New Kids Atomic Bomb.
Naja, lass uns mit New Kids Nitro anfangen. Das wird sehr cool. Als wir den ersten Film geschrieben haben,
dachten wir: Das ist es! Das ist cool! Aber wir hatten keine Ideen für den zweiten Film.
Die kamen erst, als wir den ersten Film gedreht haben. Mal sehen, wie es lÄuft.
Ich denke das wichtigste für uns ist, dass wir etwas besseres machen, als der Erste.
New Kids Nitro wird richtig geil!
Okay. Ich denke ihr werdet viel Erfolg haben. Jetzt und auch in Zukunft.
Wir finden es richtig toll, dass es in Deutschland so gut ankommt.
Man kann sich die dummen Holländer in einer lustigen Weise anschauen. Man kennt es ja. Diese Art von Leuten gibt es in jeder Stadt.
Sie hängen herum mit ihren Autos. Und das Witzige ist, in Deutschland gibt es das auch.
Ich bin sehr froh euch hier zu haben, denn ihr seid in Deutschland "Helden"
Danke, das ist lustig.